[Música]
el canciller de cuba bruno rodríguez
aseguró que peores fueron las
represiones en las protestas de las
capitales europeas que las vistas el
pasado fin de semana en la isla caribeña
una persona falleció este lunes durante
los levantamientos que rechazan la
crisis económica y el manejo de la
pandemia
en estados unidos el presidente joe
biden pidió defender los derechos de los
votantes tras la llegada de los
legisladores estatales de texas a
washington en un boicot contra la
votación de una ley en el estado que
dificultaría que ciertas personas
pudieran votar
los conservadores impulsan proyectos en
varios estados
animados por denuncias de fraude
electoral emitidas por donald trump sin
pruebas el año pasado
y francia conmemora su día nacional el
llamado día de la bastilla volvió con
los tradicionales desfiles militares por
los campos elíseos tras un año de pausa
por la pandemia el mensaje de macrón en
el despliegue fue para las operaciones
en el sahel y para la conmemorar cinco
años de los atentados y en misa tenemos
reporte
mi nombre es ángela gómez y estas son
las noticias de france 24 iniciamos en
cuba el ministro de exteriores bruno
rodríguez aseguró que vio peores escenas
de represión en las capitales europeas
que las vividas en la isla del pasado
domingo durante las masivas
manifestaciones antigubernamentales el
canciller calificó las protestas de
disturbios desórdenes y vandalismo
durante una conferencia de prensa en la
habana entretanto se conoció el
fallecimiento de un hombre de 36 años el
internet sigue intermitente en la isla y
hay más de 150 detenidos según human
rightswatch rodríguez aceptó que el país
vive una situación difícil
el acceso a la información de nuestro
pueblo es un derecho
está claro que hay condiciones complejas
que se reflejan no solo en el acceso a
internet se refleja en el acceso a la
alimentación en cuba no hay nadie
como hay en países del primer mundo en
este momento pasando hambre estamos
pasando dificultades pero aquí no hay
gente muriéndose muriéndose de hambre
pero hemos tenido los problemas la
electricidad tenemos problemas problemas
de comunicación tenemos los problemas de
conectividad y es verdad que estamos en
una situación compleja seguimos en el
caribe en haití grupos civiles y
militares retirados el rechazo en una
posible injerencia extranjera tras el
asesinato del presidente yo en el moisés
la semana pasada mientras se prepara el
funeral del mandatario el primer
ministro en funciones cloud giuseppe
solicitó el apoyo de tropas de eeuu y de
naciones unidas pero la asociación
militar haitiana de oficiales retirados
y la comisión de la sociedad civil de
haití pidieron evitar la humillación de
la intervención extranjera
no queremos que la comunidad
internacional nos diga que tenemos que
hacer no depende ni de la representante
especial de las naciones unidas para
haití ni de eeuu confíen en el primer
ministro cloud rousseff para ser
responsable del país ese es nuestro
derecho es insultante es profundamente
insultante que tanto la señora la lima
como el departamento de defensa de
estados unidos
los interfieran en nuestros asuntos
internos los necesitamos tan solo como
aliados si son en estados unidos el
presidente joe biden dijo que hay que
defender los derechos de los votantes
este llamado se une al boicot de los
legisladores demócratas de texas que
este martes llegaron a washington en
protesta contra una votación de sus
colegas republicanos que dificultaría el
sufragio para ciertas personas en varios
estados del país los conservadores
impulsan proyectos similares tras las
denuncias del ex presidente de donald
trump quien sin pruebas alegó fraude
electoral en los comicios del 2020
lo describió como una prueba para
nuestros tiempos yo bailé dice que él
planea proteger los derechos de los
votantes y culpa a los republicanos de
un asalto a la democracia gmail es
tiempo de eso para mí es simple
esto es una subversión electoral es la
amenaza más peligrosa de nuestra
historia del derecho al voto y para la
integridad de las elecciones libres y
justas nunca antes habían decidido quién
cuenta o qué votos cuentan web
los republicanos afirman que necesitan
reglas más duras para garantizar la
seguridad de los votantes luego de que
donald trump se quejará sin tener
pruebas de fraude durante las elecciones
presidenciales de 2020 varios estados
controlados por republicanos han
introducido nuevas restricciones este
año incluyendo la reducción de la
votación por correo y recortando los
tiempos de apertura de las urnas texas
es el último lugar donde ocurrió con los
demócratas saliendo del estado para
bloquear la aprobación de legislación
impulsada por los republicanos para
reformar las leyes de votación el martes
el líder de la minoría en el senado
mitch mcconnell fue despectivo sobre los
esfuerzos demócratas de gates a juárez
es interesante ver a la mayoría
demócrata en el senado preocupada por
los derechos de la minoría en el senado
estatal de tejas
creo que si vives lo suficiente vez casi
de todo por aquí
[Música]
los demócratas afirman que esas medidas
son un intento velado para restringir
los derechos democráticos argumentando
que apuntan injustamente a los votantes
afro y a los de izquierda pero por ahora
los esfuerzos por apuntalar los derechos
de los votantes se han estancado en el
congreso ya que los republicanos están
usando las reglas del filibustero una
técnica de obstrucción para asegurarse
de que las legislaciones no se aprueben
en sudáfrica continuaron los saqueos en
tiendas y oficinas contra los pedidos
del gobierno para poner fin a una semana
de violencia en la que ya fallecieron
más de 70 personas y hay cientos de
negocios destruidos también se afectaron
los hospitales que luchan por hacer
frente a una tercera ola de kobe 19 sin
suministros y escasos de oxígeno son los
peores disturbios en el país en años
tras el encarcelamiento del ex
presidente jacob zuma condenado a 15
meses por no cooperar en una
investigación por corrupción los
ciudadanos rechazan la desigualdad que
persiste 27 años después del fin de la
parte
francia celebra el día de la bastilla
que conmemora el asalto a la prisión del
mismo nombre y que dio inicio a la
revolución francesa en 1789 ya se
realizaron los tradicionales desfiles
militares por los campos elíseos
cancelados el año pasado por la pandemia
nuestra periodista natalia ruiz estuvo
en el evento y nos habló de los
pormenores regresó en gran pompa del
tradicional desfile militar del 14 de
julio presidido por emanuel mat juan
manuel mar con quien descendió en los
campos elíseos a bordo de un comando
para saludar a las miles de personas que
pudieron este año venir a disfrutar de
este evento la patrulla de francia fue
la encargada de pintar a los cielos de
la capital con la bandera de francia es
uno de los momentos que más a él le
gustan a las personas cerca de cinco mil
militares desfilaron que son varios de
los regimientos además de las escuelas
de oficiales la caballería y bueno había
dos invitados especiales
desfile de hoy por una parte los
oficiales de la fuerza tacuba son
militares europeos que participan en las
labores de contra la contra el
terrorismo en el sahel en esas regiones
de áfrica y por otra parte muy especial
los o policías municipales de niza
justamente para rendirles un homenaje a
estos agentes cuando hoy se están
cumpliendo cinco años de los atentados
terroristas de niza en nada opacó este
desfile a pesar de que hubo un poco de
lluvia un desfile que también es muy
musical en el que estuvo presente el
gobierno y la alcaldesa de parís a anna
hidalgo por supuesto estas festividades
que cierran con un gran el concierto en
la torre eiffel y fuegos artificiales
que este año tendrán el tema de la
libertad y en italia los grandes
cruceros tendrán prohibido llegar hasta
el centro de venecia desde el primero de
agosto lo anunció del gobierno después
de años de advertencias de daños
irreparables que esta actividad puede
causar a la ciudad
venecia ha sido reconocida durante mucho
tiempo como una de las atracciones
turísticas más apetecidas de europa
miles de visitantes exploran los canales
de la ciudad cada día antes de acudir en
masa a la emblemática plaza de san
marcos sin embargo a menudo se ven pasar
gigantescos cruceros interrumpiendo la
vista de los espectadores activistas y
residentes han buscado durante muchos
años que se prohíban los barcos dicen
que causan grandes olas que socavan los
cimientos de la ciudad y afectan el
frágil ecosistema de su laguna en medio
del retorno de los turistas después de
la pandemia la unesco recomendó el mes
pasado e incluir a venecia en la lista
de lugares de patrimonio mundial en
peligro y tras una revisión de las
condiciones de la ciudad el gobierno de
italia decidió el martes introducir
formalmente la prohibición declarando
las vías navegables de venecia como
monumento nacional de una decisión es
una decisión importante habrá
compensación para aquellos que sufren
daños económicos como consecuencia de
esta iniciativa pero italia finalmente
está cambiando de página la prohibición
comenzará el primero de agosto y se
aplicará a los buques que
pensé en más de 25.000 toneladas o me
dan más de 180 metros aunque los
cruceros que transporten a 200 personas
o menos todavía serán permitidos en el
centro de la ciudad
esto es france24 siga con nosotros
[Música]